so we do something fun here on the show
where I from time to time we'll play
actual voicemails that my father leaves
me but my dad isn't the only one that's
been leaving messages for old Petey
sometimes my comedian friends also leave
me a voicemail from time to time before
we play this for you I should explain
that sometimes comedians when we're
close enough will be a real mean to each
other
but it's not real mean it's like fake
mean and fun I promise so that being
said we're gonna play a very funny
voicemail from my friend Mike Birbiglia
and he Mike Birbiglia fans here Mike
called me the day I found out this show
is getting picked up for more episodes
here in the segment we call voicemails
from my friends
hi Billy TV a listen about this um
renewal of the show originally so we're
gonna do 30 more weeks but we had a an
internal meeting today and um we just
had it actually what we meant was 13
more minutes
of a show of total total yeah so we're
just gonna have you to 13 more minutes
and then that's a wrap
sorry had to come out this way and we're
really excited about the 15 minute
twisting game when you get a really big
star so you going up the top that much
and awesome all right buddy
call me I said much for Biglia that is
our show everybody thank you Mike